hey you know what
album i really loved was the record you
you and uh smoke dizzy
put out together yes don't smoke rock
don't smoke rock was crazy and then you
put the instrumentals out
what uh would you guys do um a sequel to
that
of course has that been talked about at
all
yeah we talked about it yeah i think i
think that in the smith and wesson show
i feel like
like you know it's funny because you
you've you've been doing these joint
projects and i feel like this year and
last year
we're really kind of like the wave of
like artists fully tapping in with the
producer
you know hip boy did his thing with
benny fred did his thing with alchemist
you know conrad did something with
alchemist um
who's somebody who you would like to
just zone out with and do a whole album
with that you haven't yet
closed face ghost face
that would be legendary yeah will we
have you have you guys spoken about that
ever um
we talk like a lot we talk like a lot
all the time
and um you know we'll just have to see
man
ghost's face would be insane yeah
he's my personal top five ever my
personal you know what i'm saying like
yep yep he's on my personal list too
there's two lists right there's like
your personal list and then like the
list that you
you know the like so when people be like
what's your top five or top tip man
i got top 20 man it's like what are we
talking about are we talking about like
everyone's list or like my favorites
because there's like a difference
my security list my most important list
has jadakiss on it and ghost face that's
fair
gotcha okay yeah ghost face them the
most consistent
uh one of the most consistent rappers
ever discography wise
album for album he could go against it's
like him and yay
yep so dope and i know like
if we ever work together it would be so
easy
is it easy to work with pete rock yeah
how [ __ ] yeah i just you the most you
know what you know what you know what
it's easy to work with me when you
respect me
okay so you gotta make sure that the
artist
understand see because i think that
that's an important thing to say because
if someone's going to do something with
pete rock they got to understand it's a
full collaborative process you're pete
rock you know what i'm saying
yeah you can't you can't be
disrespectful to my to my
um to the way i do
you know to the way i'm great